from we went over to america bear
natives
bear natives and we said you man move
move this is our
move that said move
young fuego j money in the cup
i'm holding my mic today guys car
this thing this thing has been stressing
me out weeks
on end so i'm gonna take it out the
camera shot
because it's pissing me off yeah man
fair play g will piss at me when we um
set up the studio we'll have the good
one i don't know about the scene
when his either comes into play cuts
yeah
it's a good look um so
november's nearly here um so enjoy guys
two episodes a week coming your way for
the month of november scooting my g or
zuma overall
and um i'm looking forward to doing it
actually
um so yeah make sure
keep us busy with your suggestions am i
the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah also
something that we spoke about a little
segment that was on patreon a little
while ago so not everyone got to see it
but potential segment about twitter
messages
we spoke about ages ago okay um
potential segments
twitter messages so we want to start
decoding twitter messages for you guys
okay let us know ladies especially
send us your twitter messages twitter or
tinder messages twitter tinder
tinder tinder sorry not twitter not
twitter tinder not twitter
tinder are you talking about sending
your tinder messages yeah
hinged messages bumble messages whatever
it makes more sense now uh
send us your messages and uh let us
decode that for you
um that'll be very interesting we
weren't obviously anonymous
yeah obviously you're not anonymous um
but yeah yeah send that in uh that'll be
funny so
yeah send sending your tinder messages
sending you am i the [ __ ]
fan request whatever you want us to talk
about yeah dms on
dm us on twitter or uh
instagram if you don't have twitter or
instagram you can email us
at shitsinggigsgmail.com i believe yeah
yeah
and that's with an i in the [ __ ] we went
full four vocals
no x or asterix or nothing there's an
eye in that [ __ ] all the vowels yeah man
so
yeah send in your requests and uh we'll
start pumping those out
um and as usual guys patreon
links in the description help us out
mission 1k let's keep moving
moving merch jump in before the new
designs come out
because they're around the corner and um
without any further ado
do we have a fun fact of the day yeah
ma'am um you know
you know they're saying daylight robbery
do you know where it originated from
of course not do you wanna have a gander
day like robbery yeah
so i would
guess it originated from
daylight robbery yeah
daylight robbery i'm assuming originates
from
i don't know bro just [ __ ] robbing
people in the day i don't know
obviously yes in context yes but the
context or the story behind
it is that when um britain occupied
ireland
um they taxed the irish people based on
the quantity of sunlight that their
windows allowed their homes to get
really yeah and then got them to pay for
sunlight
hence the phrase they like robbery
so they hang on first of all who's
measuring this sunlight
i don't have the answers to those
questions but yeah wow so if your house
sits perfectly on the ark yeah for when
the sun goes up and down you're just
[ __ ]
you're just training attached to lizzie
no wonder they wanted us out no wonder
the deep irish were like [ __ ] these man
[ __ ] these man yeah man that's why
they're cheeky republic now
speaking of just like obviously just
colonizing
and owning it yeah yeah yeah have you
ever actually thought about when i think
about like
um because you know when you think about
oh like
um it's too much sure i'll take a pillow
oh it's comfortable
speaking of pillows sorry to cut you off
the mandam in the tick tock video
time ago was that why i've got a pillow
they always think your pillow sucks
it's not pretty man it's just
comfortable yeah the [ __ ] up yeah
anyway um i've never thought about this
until it's like this is kind of stoner
chat
i've never thought about it before until
recently where i thought okay cool so
when you think about like oh english
kind of ruled the world at this time
yeah and yeah the spanish that ruled the
world this time yeah the portuguese
wrote the word this time
and all these places and you think oh i
wonder what countries ruled the world or
what countries were out here colonizing
other countries and taking over other
countries and stuff like that yeah yeah
yeah
the easiest way to figure it out is by
the language that the country speaks oh
yeah for sure i know that i know it's
obvious yeah
but the thing i've never thought about
about it yeah yeah in terms of like if i
want to figure it out with just not
thinking about
history yeah like how many countries
speak that language yeah that's the
countries that those
those countries were ruling yeah and
then i was thinking
mate brain explosion yeah
um and then i think about [ __ ] hell a
lot of countries speak english
[ __ ] hell a lot of people speak
english took
almost everything england took almost
everything no one needed pockets
we took it all no one needed pockets
we took everything what do i need
pockets for she took
everything ah given hot banged it with
that one bro
england took it all took it all american
islands you know
everywhere in europe everywhere tiny
little africa everywhere if anyone's a
keen historian let me know why did we
why were we
able to do this who gave us the goal who
gave
us the balls to do that who said we were
the ones that are going to try and
ruin the world just take over
and we're a tiny little island where did
we get the military power
to just start running things know it's
mad whichever king or queen
would have been a king whichever king
was around at that time
would have been like oh let's try and
dappy france real quick let's see [ __ ]
france let's try and see what one fam
we had going back to last week we had
the donald trump
of the medieval times back then back
then we have the donald trump of
medieval times
some french [ __ ] king was talking
smack back my mom was like
[ __ ] him and he's like sir they're seven
times our size
i don't give i don't give a [ __ ]
round up all your kids round up all the
trees all you men get your kids
and your aunties and everything we're
running over to frankia
we're right we're
this [ __ ] frog eating [ __ ] i was
talking smack it's like sire just leave
it
saya saya please and he's like now
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him all right cool man
let's go and that's we were just running
up on bare places they thought france
was a success
we'll try space we'll try to explain
we'll find spain portugal
they went everywhere international
everywhere from we went over to america
bear natives bear natives and we said
you man
move move this is our life move
that said move
[Laughter]
take your buffalo over there that's
jokes
[ __ ] off oh man and apparently we went
over there and gave them diseases
oh really so yeah a lot of the what
happened was when we went over to
america
yeah apparently when we were just
schmoozing with the natives
yeah it was during the hamilton period
that's how i remember oh right yeah
i still haven't seen hamilton it's
really good everyone says it's good
it's a musical i know i know yeah i know
but it's actually really good there
people are telling me watch it watch it
watch it
and i'm just like i like i want to but i
liked it i've got so much [ __ ] i'd
rather watch than a musical i know but
it's it's not going down i know yeah no
it's not going anywhere
um so yeah anyway we rolled up here we
just gave them bare syphilis
their flu and they just died they
weren't ready for european diseases
they'd never experienced their immune
system
wasn't keen to that speaking of um
diseases did you know that
the i think one of the first photograph
period of times where people were
wearing masks was like the 1918.
really yeah so this isn't the first time
that this has happened where we have to
wear mascara there was a flu going on
was that spanish flu or something i
think it was
probably was i think it was probably
spanish flu i think it was in like 19
something
it was the early 90s 1950s 1980s bagger
masks
there was a photograph of like a family
justin moss interesting
crazy right interesting obviously this
it wouldn't we would never know that in
our lifetime
yeah research yeah in our lifetime it's
never happened but
back then and then it was just doing it
yeah
where you're mastering in it do you know
what i mean just wear it just wear it
just wear it
people the amount of videos i see in
america all these cameras not wearing
their masks
karen's bruv you're a [ __ ] sheep
you're a [ __ ] shape i'm not wearing
it have you seen them just where you're
seeing the mask that i've got the
[ __ ] holes everywhere so
and they're the commentary you can
breathe easier obviously you can breathe
easier but you can also [ __ ] get the
dizzy there's no point having the mask
just don't
just a mask where is stupid some people
just stress that's what i mean you're
talking about before
about kind of um uh the drama
people love drama and all this stuff
yeah yeah anyone who's got time to be
beefing about master you've got too much
time on your hands
way too much time pay some bills do
something do something do something
do something with your life get into
carpentry or something wear a [ __ ]
mask
just just wear it it doesn't like it's
like let's just put all civil liberties
aside for a second
just wear it like yes it's uncomfortable
but
do you want to live it's like putting on
a johnny
it's like it's it's like you saying to
me like i'm just like
she's got bear chlamydia if i'm like all
the boys have told me and i'm like yeah
but like
what are the odds that she hasn't got it
sorted like what are the odds like
come on and you're like james just wear
it just wear a johnny and i'm like yeah
fun but
it's uncomfortable and like sometimes it
splits and you like
just wear it just wear it and i'm making
bag of excuses
and then the the fact of the matter is
is just wear it yeah
it doesn't it's like oh people the
numbers they're selling the numbers i'm
just that's like me
beefing you about disease numbers yeah
oh people are saying chlamydia is with
you forever
people say happies are with you forever
i know all this like i can't believe you
believe this conspiracy that
chlamydia actually oozes out your dick
and all this stuff and you're like james
just where the [ __ ] con the [ __ ] this
this whole i've got [ __ ] to do this back
and forth just wear the condom
yeah same thing just wear the mask or
stay at yard
yeah just do something just wear it
we don't know what she's got just wear
it
um but anyway so sorry site just yeah
side tangent little rant
um yeah fam we were just out here just
um bullying so we went over so yeah we
went over to america christopher
columbus and that
um rolled over someone was gonna say oh
it wasn't actually christopher columbus
it was something
but whatever christopher column whatever
and he was raping [ __ ]
christopher columbus i'm not laughing at
the fact that he raped [ __ ]
i'm laughing at how you said it because
i didn't know he rapes people i feel
like
i never watched it there was a show on
comedy central called drunk histories
have you ever heard of that comedians
would just get drunk
yeah yeah i've never seen it that would
be funny i've never seen it i've heard
it sometimes
i've never watched it it's
so so yes this is how it patterned from
what i know i'm not very good at history
but this is what i know terrible history
so we were just
doing bad things betting's bed scenes
christopher columbus i want to explore
family yeah i want to see
new [ __ ] yeah i want to see what's
out there yeah yeah
so he bopped over to america and was
like gang
and i think he discovered something
first i think he might have discovered
south america first or something like
that i can't remember
before he discovered america north
america i think he discovered something
first but i'm not sure
okay anyway i'm mixing up he rolled over
to let's just say he rolled over to
america
bear natives yeah and he was he come up
with the
yeah and then
i think he was kidnapping people he was
[ __ ] raping [ __ ]
and he gave bear man syphilis he just
gave all the whole syphilis
and his natives were dying they weren't
ready and he had bare flu from he was
just sneezing
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] and sneezing
everyone was dying christopher columbus
was just
nutting and dipping donald trump and
fall he didn't give up
[ __ ] he didn't give a [ __ ] he thought he
was running things
one english dawn chris up here
nutting and sneezing killing people and
[ __ ] off
oh wow and then he that was what he was
doing
and then we moved over him and then he
came back and was like yo america is
live
live i got this new joint called america
it's live
and they were like tell us more there's
just hoes
titties out beads the mandem they just
like
you don't want to get on the wrong side
of the mandate because they'll scalp
they'll cut your scalp off
so just just find some lonely hoes yeah
give these man them some cigarettes or
something
and then we're just busting nuts we're
just busting nuts over there so every
man rolled over
and then there's bare buffalo and then
and then we all rolled over down
everyone was just square up just move
move
and then they came together
and was like we need to stop this beef
yeah came together after however many
hundreds of years
[ __ ] was or whatever came together
and then everyone was like calm
here's the deal us white donnies we're
we're not leaving
yeah let's just get that get that in
your head first before we
negotiate anything
we like it here just fine yeah we like
it here just fine
so you man need to find a place to live
because this is our land now
you might need to find somewhere so you
can [ __ ] off so apparently they just
obviously that's where they have like
settlements and stuff like that
apparently um they gave up all their
land for some beads or something that's
like the story that they gave up all
their land for some beads
or some they got a [ __ ] deal okay for
all the land that they traded to
the english to have whatever so they got
[ __ ] under the stick and
that's how we came over to america and
all that stuff and then we were over
there once we'd
patent america we were just out here
stumbled across
africa and it was like cool what's going
on here
and then just bare black man dick's
swinging
big swinging and we didn't like that one
bit
we didn't
we went over to africa bare cloth
and titties and dicks swinging and we
didn't like that one bit
[Laughter]
so so whoever was over there there was
bear talon and we rolled over there and
there's bad italians over there bear
portuguese over there as well
and none of the none of us liked it yeah
we didn't like it one bit
so we was alright safe what we gonna do
about this i still want a nut
but i can't compete with this level of
pipe what are we gonna do yeah and then
someone came up with a bright idea and
was like bro
someone all i know is my house needs to
be built
it's too hot here i don't want to stay
here yeah but i don't want these man
here either yeah
so someone got a rope and a whip and
dragged older man
and said you man are coming back you
don't you clearly don't understand
english you don't understand industry
you manage living in
tents and piles of [ __ ] yeah get on the
boat
come to the there's a there's a new land
come to the west
come to the yeah come to the west
there's a new land and
and the africans were like swear and
there were newland new land new land
that's what i kept on saying new land
new la nuna nu la lu land
bear green bear grass everything yeah
you're gonna love it
yeah and they said swear yeah yeah yeah
and i said cool
like come on this this this thing this
boat thing and they were like all right
cool man it doesn't look safe
and he's like it's calm the way we
pattern it
is we make sure we're heavy so the way
the only way you can make sure it's
heavy so you don't fall off the boat
is if everyone stays together as one
unit so we get these chains
right you get these chains you put the
chains on your wrist and it's connected
to donnie behind you and
behind behind her so get that on your
wrist and
none of your mana uh cool are you man
are blessed and he's like all right safe
so everyone sits in their rows and
chains and it's cool and then
slavery began and then we they come to
new land and they're like cool you man
newland in the right place and like so
what are we doing so all right save like
you need somewhere to stay
human we're gonna put you on this stand
plantations yeah we're gonna do this
all you need to do is easy it's free
yard
just chop this thing down you're big and
strong
chop it down give it to master and
you're gonna let you stay here feed you
baby every time i swear
i swear and they said yeah just chop
that
give it my man yeah and he'll he'll
he'll like obviously he'll pay you a
food and lodging yeah yeah and then
you're in newland now he's blind
all right okay cool fam he chopped one
thing wrong
just bang toby
toby do it right that's when we knew it
was long
that's when we knew it was long short
end of the stage [ __ ] ended this [ __ ]
stick
and that's that's yeah that's how we
were just at it
and then toby that's not toby chop it
right you chopping at angles firm and
then
that's that's how it patterned g and in
english we're just out you're doing that
everywhere
yeah and now all of a sudden everyone
wants their independence
boy it's crazy man there's so many
countries i've got independence
yeah i don't really know the history of
america's independence
i don't know how it came i don't
understand i've never really looked into
the history of how i'd like someone to
explain to me if they could
send me a voice note don't type it
because i'm not going to read it yeah
and don't if you do send me a voicemail
don't expect to listen to it straight
away yeah
if i see that in there i'm going to and
but then i just remind me
just send me a voice note and be like
and put under it history of america and
english
singular because then i'll want to
listen to it but if i'm just someone
randomly sent me a voicemail i want us
to
anyway i don't really understand how we
came from
english to america yeah america's set up
his own civilization
we're still running over we're still
running america and that i don't know
when it came to americans then mind
being like big man
[ __ ] these man i don't know what we were
taking from them do you know what i mean
yeah
i don't know what they were paying us i
don't know any history of it i don't
know what it came to
it boils back to hamilton it goes to
hamilton it's it explains
i don't remember it that's in there it's
in there it's in hamilton
obviously like i said it's a musical so
you have to kind of follow it but
it's in hamilton i heard actually as
well that english england were the first
country to stop slavery
oh really i heard that i didn't i could
be completely right
i have no idea i have no idea i heard
that but
yeah i could be completely wrong
apparently someone here was just like
this ain't right
this isn't right these men are people i
don't know i want it under the
i would love to know the details of like
how
who was on board and who wasn't you know
what i mean in terms of the slaves
say we first started yeah yeah and
england went over drapes all these
man back yeah and just said these are
people we're just gonna buy and sell
yeah and they're just gonna do [ __ ] yeah
i wanna know like was anyone like
are you sure i'm 100 positive out of
people about peer pressure isn't it
you want to be in with the amongst you
know i mean you don't want to be left
out like it's
it's talking it boils down to what we
said about
i think it was about maybe five six
episodes ago about council culture and
pc culture and that is pc world we live
in
people have [ __ ] that they want to talk
about people have their own ideas and
what they want to say
but more time people just agree so it
could have been that same mentality back
then as well yeah yeah so that's my
assumption
it's wild of course it's wild because
let's say let's say um let's say there's
a guy that has
that has the power to become a slave
owner
or like there's a group of people that
have the power to become a slave man
back in the day
and you feel of some type of way about
it
but who are you to go opposed to were
you to oppose people that have the power
to
have power over other people do you know
what i mean yeah so it's just like
yeah you're just gonna go with it yeah
yeah yeah and then you kind of start
seeing the benefits of it and then
you're like oh [ __ ] it might as well
happen yeah
just like again back to the donald trump
thing
he basically hired slaves
without them knowing they're slaves oh
yeah right to do his contract for him
just didn't pay him rights yeah he was
into slavery definitely
donald trump's definitely in slavery oh
without it because he just did it he did
it
he's a descendant of a slave owner for
sure oh 100
sure um apparently there are a few
countries uh a few
companies in america i know i don't know
about in england that you can
still trace how that company you can
trace how that company
how it started you can trace back to
slavery oh really and that's when people
start you know when people start talking
about reparations and stuff like that
there's companies out there that are
massive that you can actually trace
their heritage back to slavery oh wow
and then people are like you should be
giving out reparations
yeah i think i saw that around the
george floyd era
i saw something along the lines of
people being paid out yeah i can't
remember that rings a bell
that brings up yeah i think this as well
also i don't
this is like it's reparations isn't
something i think about on a day-to-day
basis so i'm just
don't take this to heart yeah even if
just like oh jacob's just speaking
sometimes i just speak
i don't necessarily think reparations
should specifically go to
someone makes sense
like there are a lot of like let's just
say we talk about american stuff like
that there are a lot of like black
communities in america
that are suffering oh yeah of course and
that stems from slavery as well yeah
so they're in the position that they're
in in the community that they're in and
that all of that
stems back to segregation and slavery
and all this kind of stuff
yeah so if we're paying reparations i
say we if someone's paying reparations
yeah
i don't see the benefit i don't see the
big scale benefit of just paying it
to a descendant of a specific slave that
was on a specific
plantation yeah because like
you you weren't like the person that's
getting money wasn't on there yeah
so it doesn't who does it really benefit
like
yeah it doesn't really benefit like that
specific person like you should
in my opinion just put money into black
communities to make sure
that that's that's what's happening you
know what i mean that makes sense yes
that makes sense
to me it just doesn't that makes sense
it just doesn't make sense to
i feel like one person i know i
understand why they do
i also feel like when they do
do it it's kind of like okay i've done
it now shut the [ __ ] up
yeah that's the reason why they do it
yeah what i don't know if that's the
reason why they do but that could be
part of the reason why they do it could
be do you know what i mean yeah
yeah i paid you your money and also shut
the [ __ ] up yeah don't bother me anymore
yeah yeah
leave it leave it leave it let's move on
to the next stop leave it because this
is done and dusty
i paid your pee yes it's not your great
great grandfather but i paid you the
peace yeah
you know what i mean i paid you to be
sharp
this is hush money shot i wonder how
difficult it is for like big
company owners yeah to truly kind of
empathize
when they pay out reparations and stuff
like that yeah i wonder what's going
through their head i like like you said
like
this is hush money just leave it now
because obviously they're they're going
to be so disconnected
yeah it's like oh we can trace your
earnings back to slavery it's like
yeah but i did in their head like i
didn't do it
like i understand where you're coming
from but like
i start like the money that i made for
this company has nothing to do with
like slavery in in his eyes or her eyes
or whatever so when it comes to our past
preparations and all this stuff
like you said i wonder if it's a case of
if they ever
if anyone ever feels like [ __ ] you're
right i really should be paying out
this is the only reason i have this
money that this is like i should be
paying out i wonder if it's like that
or again if it's just like [ __ ] whatever
man how much do you want to shut up i
just i don't care
take your pete and get out my [ __ ]
face i wonder if it's like that
maybe i don't know i feel like it would
be more you'll be more likely to be like
that
if you grew up let's say if it was like
a family business yeah
and you've grown up wealthy yeah
and then you take over that business
yeah and all you know is privilege
yeah i wonder if you then are more
likely to be like
to be fair you're probably right because
if you if you knew for example that
your dad grew up rich and run this
massive company which means you grew up
rich and ran this
massive company and you know your kid's
going to grow up rich and run this
massive company
i wonder i feel like if it was me i
would have more of a
if people are coming to me and be like
oh this heritage that
i can personally trace back because i
know that my dad had it
and his dad had it and his dad had it if
i knew if i grew up like that
i might be a bit more inclined to be
empathetic and understand that like
i know why i grew up like this yeah and
i knew all of this was handed to me yeah
all of this massive company was handed
to me yeah and i know that for a fact
yeah regardless if i work hard every day
to maintain it i know it was just given
to me
yeah i might be a bit more likely to be
like you're probably right
because if you if i if you're telling me
we can trace it back to slavery
and i can look at my family tree and
know that it came from slavery yeah then
i might be more likely to be back damn
straight yeah
yeah yeah whereas in today's business
doesn't usually work like that
like a ceo doesn't usually come from
the sciences he's probably someone who's
worked their [ __ ] way up
to being ceo level yeah and they're
moving laterally or diagonally
over to this company yeah and now they
run this company yeah and there's some
strangers coming to them saying you best
give me some [ __ ] money yeah
because this company trails back to and
then they're probably thinking that
ain't got dick to do with that's not my
business
yeah yeah yeah i ain't got [ __ ] to do
with me i just happen to work here i
just happen to be the man in charge
i'm an employee
i might be at the top of the food chain
but i'm a [ __ ] employee get out my
face
that's when they might be more likely
but this is hush money shut up
shut up take it and get the [ __ ] up my
face
get out my office shut up buy some fried
chicken and
[ __ ] off
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you now god we talk a lot of [ __ ]
oh
so much yeah funny hilarious that was
funny anyway
uh [ __ ] question yeah
oh god what was i gonna ask you i don't
know do you like [ __ ] girls in the
shower
um i would say i don't like it but i
wouldn't say it's
a i've done it a few times i've not done
it a lot um
and it depends on the shower like it has
to be like a bath shower it can't be a
stall like a box shower yeah i've never
done that before because i'm not
it's that's just awkward yeah yeah yeah
yeah but yes i have
do i like it again it depends on like
the size of the girl as well like height
wise
yeah because it makes that makes a huge
difference oh it does yeah stand up sex
like
she has there's only a few positions
that could put you in stand-up sex so
yeah
yeah it depends on how yeah yeah do i
like it i'm not i don't think i've got
enough experience
in it to have a huge judgement call up
about it but
i i won't knock it yeah yeah
i will do it if the time if the mood is
right i'm i'm there yeah man
wait i won't do it every day chow six is
a weird one for me okay that is like um
it's a weird one in that it like for one
do you remember a few weeks ago when i
um
when i said about
she told me to get my kit off and i felt
naked yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's how i feel with shower sex
because i'm in the shop because like
i'm either in the shower first yeah
someone's clothed that one time when
someone isn't
when it comes to shower sex someone's
naked and someone isn't okay
and if i'm the one naked yeah and it's
like in the shower already yeah
and my girl's coming in draws in curtin
back i'm a bit like
what's going on yeah what's going on
yeah and then if it's the vice versa
where like i'm like i'm getting in the
shower and i'm gonna she can yeah she
can see me get completely naked
all the lights are on yeah and i feel
naked yeah because my dick's probably
not harder this year yeah
yeah yeah i know what you mean i know
what you mean and um
and then once i'm in the shower with
them yeah and all stuff
obviously lips and lip scene getting
your dick in there
it's like going down a dry water slide
your dick just go
before it gets the lube lube yeah
it's horrible my sorry to cut you off my
difference in experience with for um
shower sex
is we're already showering together like
the intent wasn't to have showers
oh okay we've just gone to shower
together okay and then it's
radically happened so that awkwardness
for me has never been there again i've
not had shower sex that many times
i've had it like three times in my life
i've had it a handful of times that's
about it
the the first time yeah the first time
the one i've told you about the first
time haven't i yeah
the first time
yeah i had to think
yeah yeah so the first time i ever had
shower sex yeah
talking to a girl she was i was at home
i would never sit together before she
said to me
she messaged me like i'll just come back
from the gym you mind if i slap over
yours for a shower
and i was like sure okay cool and then
i remember i was younger at this point i
remember
she i was like cool she got there i'm
like yeah second door on the right
and she's alright safe she walks in got
starkers
the door was open and i could hear the
shower running yeah and i must've been
on my laptop or something just keying
away not really thinking much and she
was like are you coming or what
fam my heart beat oh i bet
my heart beat oh i bet i was like huh
i'd never had a shower of a girl before
my heart beat b and i was like
okay cool and this is it this is with
her like i had to go in the bathroom
she's already in the shower ah that's
nah that's pressure and i had to get
naked
in front of her yeah you wouldn't have
been hard you wouldn't have been hard
slumping you would not have been hard
yes
and then because we're standing up
when we're getting into it i'm getting
in and i'm just trying i'm getting in
and i'm like trying to get a bit of
water in that
splash myself because it's not effective
it's not getting me it's not a waterfall
it's not getting me so i'm just there
like
trying to splash myself to get a bit
extra moisture
and then like with lips and lips and
lips in and i'm very conscious
that my dick is getting hard yeah by the
second yeah so i'm thinking she
is aware that it's like creeping up
she could feel it climb she can feel it
climbing up her leg
and then when it was at full mast
like the weird foreplay [ __ ] that was
going on i just like slid it in between
her legs that's what i got
as a full plating and in the moment it
seemed all right but when you think
about your hindsight
she's standing up straight i'm standing
up straight and i'm just sliding my dick
in and out of her legs
and in my head i'm like this is sexy but
in
if someone walked in i'm just there like
thrusting in thin air
so [ __ ] and then it slid in but it was
awkward sliding
i think it was face to face
yeah and i tried to like dip it under
and get it
and it was just like [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
and i think we did that for a little bit
and then did some other stuff but yeah
it was just like
i've had a couple i've had one i've had
one shower sex that wasn't that long ago
that was
it was
[Laughter]
it was delish that's hilarious um but
yeah shower six is a
iffy one yeah yeah i agree
if you want i fully agree um this is the
slide
this is a big tangent but i just
remember i've just this is something
that i've remembered i've
i must have told you about it before
okay but we haven't spoken about in a
very long time
it's about one of our friends okay um
so there was a time
this is not to do with shower sex but so
there was a time in manchester
coincidentally
okay when i was before i moved here away
before
i must have been about i want to say i
was 20 years old
oh wow okay uh 19 or 20. oh wow
we came here for new year so me and one
of our friends came here for new you
know who was yeah and
came here for new year's eve yeah and um
we came to manchester yeah got a hotel
and had a good time and we were out um
he was talking to a girl at the time and
so she came back to the hotel with us
they didn't [ __ ] or anything yeah but
she just slept there with us
okay um in his bed obviously and um
so we get back to the hotel
chat and chat and chatting everyone goes
to brush their teeth
use the toilet everything we go to bed
we say our good nights and we go to
sleep fam
yeah it's like a murder mystery
we wake up the next day yeah and she
goes into the bathroom
yeah and i hear a scream
i hear a scream and a laugh so it's like
a murder scene scream
yeah so everyone wakes up i'm tired
and she goes in the bathroom close the
door and all he is
then there's a breath and then she
starts laughing no way and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah so she's
like james
james come in here why should she call
me i don't know james come in come in
you've got to see this
fam i walked in and she was like
look in the bath i look in the bath
and there is a log of [ __ ]
dead bullseye center of the bath
one log no streaks no mess
no extra nuggets one clean log of [ __ ]
square in the bath what family you never
told me i've never told you this from
the mysterious [ __ ]
so we call um our boy and we're like yo
what's this and we have to backtrack now
and we say who was last in the bathroom
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and it was my
man
okay and he's like it was not me yeah
obviously it was not me
and we're like probably was you why you
[ __ ] in the bath bruh
yeah and he's like buff it wasn't me so
fam is the biggest mystery of all time
that it was just like dead son now we've
i know it wasn't him but i will still
accuse him to this day that it was yeah
either me him or her was
so drunk that we just stumbled in and
had a [ __ ]
in the bath just the uno uno
and it landed clean it must have landed
like you must have to squat there
and it's just like yeah
fam the most clean [ __ ] you've seen
and then either that happened
or someone knew there was [ __ ] in
that room
and the cleaner came in and just dropped
one and dipped
so this can you describe
the bathroom like where everything like
so you brush your teeth you walk in so
let's say you walk in
yeah bath is on your right with
obviously shouts as a bathtub with a
shower attached yeah yeah yeah
sink and everything is on your left yeah
mirror is everything on your leg is
there a curtain or is it like on the
left
side is a glass ting i think it was a
glass ting okay
and none of you noticed it when you were
like none of us noticed
that when you're brushing your teeth but
we wouldn't have any reason to look over
there
yeah i think only your only reason you'd
look in the tub is if you're about to
get in a shower
okay and especially if we were drunk
drunk the night before we wouldn't have
looked in the tub
yeah so i'm assuming someone it was a i
think it was a hate crime
i think it was a hate crime some
consuela
didn't like who was up in the room no i
decided to leave her her
trademark huge turd family you've never
told me really you have
the mysterious poo bro
you have never told me this it's the
weirdest phenomenon in your life you've
never really
never from now there's literally like as
far as
conspiracies go there's like
um aliens
mi5 secrets the mysterious poo
no one knows why go on with this poo
phone that is
the weirdest thing i i wouldn't know
how i'd react if i was seeing that i was
pissing myself laughing
but then i'm like to now want to think
back here i'm just like
completely perplexed like how i don't
know
i don't know one of you would have done
it it was
not me i know that
don't accuse me i'm not
cute i'm just saying there's no way
someone came in the room before took a
[ __ ] and dipped
purposely in the bathroom and dipped for
you man to wake up and see it
i i find that impossible but then again
there's no way
one of you like if you need to [ __ ] you
just don't [ __ ] the one
do you don't that's the thing you don't
just [ __ ] the one it was a hate crime
[ __ ] because they
in my head they scurried in there and
they just needed some [ __ ] out
they didn't want to release all their
bowels in in my head if it was a hate
crime
they've opened the door they're scurried
in they've made sure no one's home
they've gone into the bathroom and
they're like i want a [ __ ] [ __ ] in
this bath
and then they just they got one out and
dipped
because you're right you don't just one
log it and then you're done you're done
you don't
no tissue no nothing
that's weird that's it and the way it i
know it wasn't me because the way
the weight was patterned the way it was
so central and clear
you'd have to squat and do it yeah and i
don't even know how to squat and [ __ ]
do you know what i mean i only know the
toilet weight yeah so even if i was in a
drunken haze yeah yeah
i wouldn't know to do it yeah i would
have fallen in my own [ __ ] yeah
yeah i would have slipped back yeah i
don't even know how to do that that
makes sense
so do you not think how high was the
rise of the bath the slope out
yeah what do you mean because you climb
you have to climb into the bath right
it's not like a walk-in bath oh you have
to climb in yeah yes but how high is
that thing
so maybe someone could have sat on it
and edged back
no because it was angled this way length
ways oh
yeah it was angled lengthways
okay that's weird man that was crazy
that's blowing my mind that's why pluto
ting that is a pluto there's a proper
whodunit
proper who done it bro i have no idea oh
wow you have never told me
really you have never told me i thought
i had yeah i guess it was just the three
of us that know about it then
it was weird bro and thousands of people
and now obviously thousands of people
know but
i don't know wow
it's a good story though i like that i
like that i just want to get to the
bottom of it
it's done now imagine the cleaners face
the next day
fam livid
um if i was that cleaner
do you remember
there was um oh [ __ ] so you know what i
was talking to you about humans earlier
yeah the show yeah yeah so obviously
it's about androids or robots or
whatever they call them synths synthetic
humans
they have an ability to obviously change
the octaves of their voice
okay so there's one woman this one um
robot
she is like um what do they call it
what do they call it when they're um
like conscious
that she is um
that's a word but anyway she's got a
conscious like she's human so she can
talk like she's
humanly conscious doesn't just react
yeah she's like artificially intelligent
like she is
um so she is
she has to pretend to not be um
against s what's it called it's
um you know what stuff like this when
there's stuff on the tip my tongue i
can't think about it
i already know there's people in the
screen like this
yes yeah no um
it's uh we'll come to you don't worry
all right cool so anyway she's
she's like off conscious mind and she's
up in a
brothel like a robot brothel okay and
she hates it there but she can't break
cover
okay because if people find out who she
is or what she is like she's dead
okay um so she's there and she wants to
scream
fam so she raises her pitch to a point
you know when like a dog whistle point
yeah no one can hear it yeah there is a
pitch to that level and
[ __ ] screams oh really and the amount
of frustration that's how i imagine the
cleaner was
when they walked in and just saw a
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the bath
and then just reflected on their life
and was just like
i would have snapped the broom why me
yeah yeah imagine you got that floor you
have to do the whole floor and then
and then you just get that you're
knackered your ankles are hurting from
you've been up since five
and you're just there and you're just
like i [ __ ] hate this joke
and you walk into room 419 and there's
just a turd in the bath
and then she's probably thinking they
left this here for me obviously that's
what she then they left this here for me
to deal with
i hate people i [ __ ] she probably
quit that day she probably did quick
she's like
it's just not worth it i don't deserve
it i remember i used to work for
um when i was i used to be a pt in this
leisure center
um and the lifeguards used to have the
most skivvy duties
because being a lifeguard is easy yeah
it's just you dos
basically and you only need x amount of
lifeguards at any one time okay
but they'd always have bare lifeguards
in their building because of the
rotation of the ships and stuff because
i
think you're not supposed to be
lifeguarding for a certain amount past a
certain amount of hours
okay because like people were falling
asleep bruv oh yeah
so they used to have to rotate shifts so
um just bear lifeguards so obviously to
keep them busy so they're not just
sitting around
they would make them do all the skivvy
jobs pick up litter
[ __ ] fold towels like anything to
think of keeping them but they were
basically cleaners i went into the
changer i remember i taught a spin class
one time yeah and these times in the
hierarchy i'm
i'm lavish yeah yeah in the high rank i
just thought of spin glass and i've got
a healthy glaze
yeah and i'm about to get in the shower
i'm just chin wagging with bad clients
yeah okay i just got my i'm shredded at
this point as well i've got my towel on
yeah
and i've just got a healthy glaze i
listen yeah and i'm thinking i'm feeling
good endorphins are coming from the spin
class as well
everyone's chatting my ear off and i'm
like yeah yeah i walk into the
shower cubicles and there's a lifeguard
one guy i was
i was friends with on his hands and
knees picking pubes
and hair out of the gutter of the
showers
and i was like
nah i'm not doing that
i'm not dude that would make me vomit
vamp that'll make me vomit it reminded
me of super remember the film super bad
yes when mclovin's trying to buy beer
yes fake id yes
and he goes to close the fridge and bare
beard just falls over the floor
and then when the the person comes up
and said did you do this
a man says nah but it's a health hazard
like clean it and kicks it
it's like clean up he's currently a man
walks up and he's like
ah [ __ ] of my life that's the first time
i've ever had [ __ ] my life
and it hit me when he said that because
he's just like why is my life
like this people are dashing beer on the
floor and kicking it at me saying clean
it
in donnie was on his hands and knees
picking out pubes out of the drain
nah man i wouldn't ah man pour some
[ __ ]
drain thing down here pour some hot
water and you're nice
you're nice there were bare hair down
there
nah nah i'm not doing that
hands down i'm not doing that that's not
my job title
that's not my job i'm here to save lives
literally i'm here to save lives and you
ain't making me pick up pubes on my bare
hands
no gloves he might have had a club i
can't remember
i hope he had a glove he was everyone
said it was his hands and knees his
knees were red and wet
his knees were red and wet that's all i
remember and he was sighing
he had had enough who had it had really
had enough
nah man he was at the end of his tether
and i was like
big man no mom there's levels to this no
mom just i'm not doing that job
no you can't make me no one can make me
do that
i wouldn't do that if i was on probation
if someone said community service thing
that's content you're on probation
do this i'll say no send me back send me
to pence send me back send me some pen
with my [ __ ] dignity
that's that next man's pubes and hair
fan hands and knees hands and knees and
we had
speak full circle yeah in that place
yeah there was one sus guy that no one
could clock he was a serial [ __ ]
you've told me about him before not on
this podcast
you've told me about him before did you
work with lewis back then oh no actually
there's two
there was one of this this leisure
center yeah and when i moved to david
lloyd to work there there was one there
too yeah and that's when i was working
with lewis yeah you've told me about
that one maybe
i'll talk about the first one you told
me on that one this infamous [ __ ] in
both places
yeah no one knew who it was no one knew
who it was and you'll just
open a [ __ ] door one day and there'll
be a turd sitting in the drain
and then you just press the red button
lifeguard would scurry in and deal with
that
no lifeguard again [ __ ] i'm not
dealing with that way
i'm not [ __ ] human human [ __ ]
a life i would bang my manager in the
face
i'm quitting that day cause the fir
imagine
imagine you go in as in as a [ __ ]
you're going on your first day as a
lifeguard they tell you all the rules
and regulations are
wide ready of what you have to do my
polo shirts ironed
vamp i'm excited i'm excited for my
first day i'm about to make some real
money saving lives
and then they just say to you oh just to
let you know just keep lifeguards busy
you have to do a few extra curricular
activities etc fall asleep we've got
seven or eight lifeguards on on route
on job rather yeah i get i understand
you're on
you're on the first shift boom the bell
rings
from this bear light's spinning i'm
saying what's going on going on
drowning who's
me all right i'm about it i've never
done this before i'm about it
all right big man there's a [ __ ] in the
sink there's a [ __ ] in the toilet
there's a [ __ ] in the [ __ ] drain
i beg you scoop that what
pardon what are you man talking about
cuz why you man actually talk
i don't i would honestly think dead man
are playing a prank on me do you know
what i mean like
you're hating me on my first day yeah
it's like a little initiation thing
say no more hahaha spud you you man deal
with that i'm going back to my post
shout me when there's a real emergency
and they'd be like nah nah nah nah nah
remember extracurricular thing i was
talking to you man about before
this is one of those this is the thing
scoop that
big man customers need a shower big man
big man oh
i'll spin your jaw i'm like what
you can't leave that out at the t's and
c's from you can't leave that out the
smallest
black and white in my cotton track you
will be asked to pick up [ __ ]
because i was straight saying nah nah of
course i'm saying no
i'll say nah i'll go home and tell my
mom never
never no in my mind back then she would
have told me to do it
number my mom back then she didn't care
about my dignity
she would say do it do it if you're in
my yard if you want to see them under
this roof you need a job you better
[ __ ] pick up [ __ ]
the fam me and my manager would go aye
i'll scream
i'll scream at her why you put me
through
what did i do to you nah i'm here to
make money
earnestly ah
that's that's the next thing that's
that's when you tell someone you're
nothing
oh wow yeah yep you want nothing yeah
get on your hands and knees and pick up
some [ __ ]
you're nothing this is why i can't bro
this is what i told you
this is why i can't have a normal job
stuff
yeah obviously i don't clean up [ __ ]
yeah but
the lifeguard analogy is so true to
earth because it's like this is not what
they signed up yeah yeah
obviously if your job is picking up [ __ ]
you know what you're here to do yeah
you know what you're hitting black and
white it's in a teaser and you zone out
and you just get on with it
you sign the dotted line and you [ __ ]
you know where you're at
yeah but i'm here to protect people i'm
a public servant [ __ ]
and these men are telling me there's
pubes and [ __ ] that needs cleaning up
it's my turn to do it what do you mean
but lifeguard i took a course every i
got a certificate cuz
i've got a certificate fab i paid for
this course
i paid for this you might not tell me to
pick up [ __ ]
how about i pick up and put on your desk
i will smear it on man
i just wanted that one i'll smear it on
you know when it catches her nose on
their lip
i will smear it on him and run i say
[ __ ] you bro prick
fam i will say [ __ ] you nah
i'm worth more than this that's not uh
that's not
that's what you say like when you when
you're in the corporation flex obviously
at my job this is the thing obviously
i'm not about
no one in my job is telling me just pick
up [ __ ] yeah but obviously there's
certain jobs
yeah but you think you're here for one
thing yeah but you're just a servant
yes do as you're told yeah that's your
contract yeah do what you're [ __ ]
told
to the point where you if i need you to
clean up [ __ ] you better get in your
hands and knees and clean up some
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what your worth is for six and
the thing is as well the people who have
the worst jobs get paid the least
oh yeah for sure these men cleaning up
[ __ ] they were under 18 as well
so they're on like six pound an hour
five pound an hour
low minimum you didn't even need to pay
them minimum wage
you can pay them what you want
disrespectful no wonder they needed a
job
fam i was thinking this is grown men no
this was teenagers
oh they got their whole lives ahead of
them and this is their first experience
of paid work
cleaning up [ __ ]
and they're told to be grateful at least
you have a job
nah i'd rather be poor
fam that's a shame
it is a [ __ ] shame that's the [ __ ]
those were tough times
g [ __ ] lifeguards go through it brav
[ __ ] lifeguards go through it they go
[ __ ] do it um
am i the [ __ ] am i the also
i went there
cool am i the [ __ ] for telling my
girl
my girlfriend i
hate bad spelling and grammar and all
this stuff am i the [ __ ] for telling
my girlfriend
she is possessive when she wants to
control my social media
this is such a say that again am i the
author i'm either telling my girlfriend
she's possessive
when she wants to control my social
media so you're not the answer
easy my girlfriend goes through my
following list on social media
and continually accuses me of being a
creep
for following people who make her
insecure okay i never stalk anyone
online or ever do
anything like that but she's convinced
that i do
recently she told me that i should
deactivate my accounts
and just use one with her i did not
agree
and she said i'm being suspicious for
not agreeing with her
i got angry and i told her that she's
possessive
and that her behavior is not normal she
blames me for making her insecure and
justifies what she's doing
using that i know it sounds childish and
some kind of teenager relationship
but i'm just as baffled by her actions
big man off the bat dump
that girl deactivate your social media
and let's share one
have you lost your [ __ ] mind i would
smear a [ __ ] on her
i would spit she would be the yeah i'd
smear [ __ ] all over
have you lost your [ __ ] mind
i'm acting suss because i won't
deactivate my social media accounts and
share one with you the audacity
i'm not sharing anything with you not
anymore
fam i'm out i'm not sharing a bed with
you this
is this is the biggest no-brainer am i
the [ __ ] ever
i'm ow bro it's easy
it's easy that's
crazy it's easy
get rid of her get rid of her
everything she needs to go get rid of
her she needs to go
what's she doing here how would she even
put you in that situation
bro that's the thing as well is like a
lot of people talk about like obviously
manipulating people emotionally and like
you can charm people and manipulate them
in certain ways yeah i don't think it's
actually spoken about enough is how
i'm sure men do it as well but obviously
when i think people
think that i'm not necessarily sexist
but like i always take the guy's side
but the fact is just because i'm a guy
so i can only speak from
other experience like i don't experience
guys being manipulative to girls
because i'm not a girl get manipulated
you know yeah i know what you mean
yeah so i can only speak from my own
experience yeah but i've
obviously when a girl or i know guys do
this as well
i know guys do this when they're being a
[ __ ] simp
guys like and girls like when they use
their insecurities
and their anxiety as an excuse for you
to change
how you act and the things that you like
this like
oh you're making me insecure because
you're acting suspicious because of this
and that and you follow this person and
follow this person
and that makes me feel a certain way
like why would you not just
give me your password like why would you
not just do this like that's
manipulation yeah that is full-on
manipulation
yeah like you're guilt-tripping me into
doing [ __ ]
makes sense that's full of manipulation
yeah i agree like people don't see that
that way but it actually is
because guys will nine times out of ten
if you don't want to lose your
girlfriend you're giving and you're
doing whatever she says kind of thing
yeah and unless you guys do it as well
especially if the guy's punching if the
guy's punching punching
he'll do whatever it takes he'll do
whatever it takes
not to lose that it's not worth it
banging
and you know you're average oh she loves
you because you're funny that's
it you're doing it every time you're
sharing a [ __ ] facebook with her
i've seen people who share facebook
before
disgusting behavior disgusting behavior
i don't even have facebook's i don't
even
i don't even know when people share a
[ __ ] i'll speak to clients and
sometimes and stuff and they're like
oh cool i'm like excuse me
what's your email address or something
and i like um
i'll tell you what let me give you my
personal one and i'm like cool all right
that's what i was asking for anyway yeah
all right save and they're like yeah my
personal email address is like um
it's david and it's his name david it's
david cool
and jane what david
a n d yeah jane j
a n e okay
at the smiths dakota uk
david and jane at the smithsonian why
are you
sharing an email address with your wife
and why is the domain
the smith this is what's wrong with
gmail why do people go to these links
why did your family need to create his
own email domain
so you can share an email inbox why
it does have a view it happens all the
time
you thought i was making up i've never
seen that in my entirety
it happens all the time making up their
own domains
yeah the smiths or the johnsons or
something
they've got their own email domains no
way it's so extra
how many emails are you getting that
this is a requirement for you
some people are such [ __ ] olds in
relationships it pisses me off
you're allowed to be your own person you
are you're allowed to be in
like when you're like just because
you're a couple doesn't mean you have to
be
just that yeah it's just so whack
yeah yeah anyway you're not an [ __ ]
cause i don't even know why you asked
that dumb question bro yeah
you're probably a nicer for asking yeah
you're more of an [ __ ] for wasting my
time having to read that
then you are for telling your girl she's
crazy she's nuts she's clap she needs to
leave
oh i would love to be there's so many
times that some of these uh my eyes are
gonna be a fly in the wall yeah yeah
yeah yeah and just scream leave her
she's nuts stop it but um anyway man
rapidly see you my next week